[Music]
hillsdale college was founded on the
frontier in 1844 and it was founded by a
bunch of free will baptist preachers who
came out here on the frontier to start a
college they were very serious about
high learning and about the perpetuation
of freedom and very much founded the
school to admit from its beginning
people of any race both sexes so it was
pretty radical
hillsdale college is stuck by what it
was founded to do since the beginning
and the thing it was founded to do it's
really a set of four things but they
make one thing together we're interested
in god and we're interested in character
and which is freedom interested in
learning and learning of a very high
kind
and so we keep those things in mind all
the time
so we start with that
and then through a long history uh full
of good times but also full of
the three worst wars in american history
the civil war in the first and second
world wars
through the great depression
through vast changes in the country
it has clung to those original purposes
and they are beautiful
[Music]
you